they can't reach those big guns and they
just keep dropping in there's nothing
you can do like you know big bullseye on
top of the hill wait you can't be safe
you can be lucky I can't be safe you can
be lucky jump landing all over bouncing
off you and you're just as scared every
time and it gets worse closer they get
the more they throw the more you get
scared and you get up wonderful feeling
just to be alive be able to walk around
after one of those if I live a hundred
years I'll just never ever be able to to
tell the story the way it really
happened these young kids who just run
up to him and when we were all boxed in
they were all around and they're all
over our perimeter and withdrawn
grenades and I got pretty close and just
run up to one of these kids and say
marine we're gonna get out of here
aren't we and a kid look up to you and
say you're damn right we are skipper
those Marines are talking about a place
named Con Thien an obscure American
outpost in Vietnam as Tarawa Iwo Jima
and Guadalcanal were once obscure Con
Thien azov' bitterly exposed target just
two miles below the DMZ American Marines
have been under fire there since last
May in just the last four weeks they
have suffered over 70 dead 1000 wounded
in the next half hour we shall examine
the ordeal of Con Thien
[ __ ] yen is here two miles south of the
Demilitarized Zone of the narrow top of
South Vietnam 12 miles inland from the
South China Sea
it is a desolate hilltop collection of
guns and bunkers looking north across
the DMZ into North Vietnam it's crucial
importance lies in the fact that it's on
a main infiltration route into the south
the loss of content could help open the
way for the estimated 35,000 communist
troops now massed in the DMZ area its
loss would block the construction of
that electronic barrier along the DMZ to
seal off South Vietnam from the north
but more than that if Schloss would give
the North Vietnamese that one big
elusive propaganda victory they've been
searching for at such a cost in lives
they would prize a victory at Con Thien
as a miniature replica of their victory
over the friendship the NBN flew in 1954
Con Thien is vulnerable it is the least
defensible of any of the American
outposts because it's so close to North
Vietnamese territory the enemy artillery
about a hundred big guns plus mortars
and rockets can pound Con Thien
around-the-clock with devastating effect
and our ground troops cannot go into
North Vietnam to knock out those guns
for the Marines at Con Thien this is
what it's like
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
gorgeous you motivate them Chopra
[Music]
which I ran
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
yeah
[Music]
[Music]
eight zero one zero zero zero one zero
zero
[Music]
eighty-one should be able to do that as
well wave let's get them on there over
okay here are the two attacks you see
what that was smoke is there that bought
the small planet about 300 meters right
where that big tree is out there 300 to
400 meters
[Applause]
what happened to your squad oh there was
hit most almost hit by shrapnel and
there was metal plate don't tell me you
came here at full strength I had 13 min
when I came and it's four days later now
and how many are still here six I think
we're just uh occupying ground then
losing too many men how losing too many
men we were stay or two much longer we
wouldn't have much left of this platoon
let alone the company I see what about
three four people get it a day
not not real bad enough to be medevac
cut my platoon down well isn't that all
part of war as the generals say sure it
is but for seven months up here at one
battalion ain't gonna have much left it
if that's part of war that'll rotate a
little more I think send us back where
we can get new men and train them see
we're getting new men out here they
coming out what you might call green and
then they do I don't know really how to
act the rifles have been jamming the
buds been slowed everything down and the
artillery comes in everywhere and just
gets pretty funeral and frustrating
sometimes so a really depressing part
about it is
[Music]
there isn't really much you can do you
know I mean you see it around come in
you see your buddies get blown away and
stuff like that well I can't say that
I'm scared stuff but I'm scared I mean
after a while it you know it's gonna
come and you can't do nothing about it
and you just look to God it's about the
only thing you can do would you get any
idea from up around content how the war
is going if we if we don't get some more
people up in this area real quick and
we're no against more b-52s real fast
and these people are gonna be all the
way down at the name before anybody
knows it everybody agree with that what
kind of support are the Marines getting
general Westmoreland says the Americans
are responding with the greatest
concentration of conventional firepower
in history the u.s. artillery fire is 10
times greater than the enemy's it comes
from Dong Ha kam lo Jolin the other out
both corners of what is called
Leatherneck Square from these big guns
at Camp Carroll the batteries fire off
as many as 10 thousand shells daily
lobbing them over the heads of the men
at Con Thien deep into the Demilitarized
Zone and then there are the b-52 bombers
striking from nearby Thailand
they pound the zone day in day out with
tons of explosives
[Music]
[Music]
with this saturation why haven't the
North Vietnamese positions been
destroyed
Marine commanders say the enemy gun most
of them highly mobile role in and out of
deep caves and tunnels only a direct hit
can silence them and there has been no
silence at Con Thien the story of how
Con Thien came to be a miniature Korea
began last May the Marines there were in
construction battalions clearing strips
to help protect against attacks the
outpost was little more than a few
trenches dug and a hilltop still green
and unscored man by 300 South Vietnamese
civilian air regulars advised by a
handful of American Special Forces
troops the few bunkers looked more like
temporary homes for the men who were
there to operate the graters and
earthmovers but they were some
protection against occasional artillery
attacks then things got rougher on the
morning of May the 9th burning tanks and
personnel carriers marked a battle that
had begun at 2:30 a.m. and lasted until
after daybreak the hilltop was strewn
with dead two hundred two hundred
Auckland like this one North Vietnamese
regulars the enemy had struck with a
force of 1,200 men captured enemy
weapons were gathered from all over the
perimeter the cost to the Americans in
that first battle at Con Thien included
124 wounded of these 110 were Marines
the rest
Special Forces men and there were our
own death 44 Americans all together all
of them Louise the first to fall at ton
here
for the next few months there was less
action than preparation for action the
Marines had come to stay to take control
of Con Thien from the South Vietnamese
the plan now was to establish a post on
the hilltop that could be more easily
defended that meant more bunkers and
well protected gun emplacements the
expectation then was for another ground
assault enemy artillery was fairly
inactive until July when it got busier
the Americans retaliated with air
strikes for the rest of July and August
the Marines at Con Thien used their own
guns to good effect the ammunition an
endless supply came in daily and it was
used up daily this was the end of a
supply lifeline that began in Danang and
arrived at Con Thien by way of Dong Ha
six miles to the south
they were tents nearby to house a
complement that included about a
thousand men no matter how you look at
it those were better days there was more
time for things like the casual cleaning
of weapons but nothing at Con Thien has
been casual since September came well
the first 25 days of this month Con
Thien had to fight back against ground
assaults and a sudden calculated
escalation of enemy artillery the most
intense artillery barrage of the war at
times the shouts of incoming could be
heard above the noise of our own guns
there has been a slight let up in the
last few days but Marines still must
patrol the perimeter of Con Thien and
for these men the danger is multiplied
by the threat of ambush the kind of war
that's going on around Con Thien
inspired one young marine to put his
feelings into a poet when youth was a
soldier and I fought across the sea we
were young in cold hearts of bloody
savagery point of indignation children
of our time we were orphans of creation
and dying in our prime what made you
write that call just the way things are
the commander's in Vietnam the men who
must decide when ordeals must be born
look at the ordeal at Con Thien from a
different vantage
we talked with general william
Westmoreland commander of American
ground forces and Lieutenant General
Robert Cushman who commands the Marines
there there have been some questions
from outside and in your own command
structure all the way down to some
privates I met on content about the
defense of that outpost and some who
perhaps aren't as confident as the
general may be well when you sit in a
place such as that and the night comes
on you really have to rely upon yourself
and upon supporting fires and naturally
the confidence may not be as great as it
is back here where I can see the many
forces that can be brought to bear and
which those right on the spot may not be
aware I am confident that we can hold
this area and we have been doing it
furthermore from what reports we've had
from prisoners and documents we've been
hurting the enemy badly they have
attempted to make it appear that they
are winning a military victory their
target is American public opinion they
had hoped that by inflicting these
casualties it being fully understood by
them that the casualties inflicted upon
their ranks were unknown to us that they
would achieve their psychological
victory and this is the only way they
can conceivably win this war Conte and
then you're saying is not really a
military action but a political or
psychological warfare precisely their
objective is political in psychological
it is designed to weaken the will of the
American people to make it appear in
American and public and world opinion
that they are stronger than they are in
fact and to discourage our resolve we
asked two of our CBS news correspondents
who've been under fire with the Marines
at Con Thien for an assessment of the
situation there
lawrence and robert chacne we asked them
first what other Marines saying right
now about content Oh Mike if the Marine
happens to be an infantryman he feels
that he'd rather be someplace else I've
heard a lot of Marines say that Con
Thien is a very poor place to defend
because the Marines can't move out on
the ground with infantrymen and with
tanks to attack the positions from which
the North Vietnamese are firing their
artillery that's in the other side of
the border
now if the Marines were to pull back
five or ten miles in the North
Vietnamese were to follow them with
their artillery and the Communists would
no longer be invulnerable from marine
counter-attack on the ground
the marine riflemen onk-onk N or grunts
as they call themselves would rather be
anywhere out in an operation marching or
back at the rear sleeping anywhere but
content in their simple teenage
philosophy they don't understand the
significance of holding on to what
you've got or as it said in the Orient
saving face the Pentagon gives orders to
the generals and the generals give order
to the Colonel's and so on and all the
orders are obeyed but the grunts don't
seem to understand that they're holding
content because of a Pentagon decision
to win the war with a kind of modern
Maginot Line that hasn't been built yet
and what lies ahead for content in the
coming weeks there's not likely to be
much change Mike as long as the monsoons
lasts the heavy range is supposed to
start this month and their last two or
three months and during that period it's
unlikely that the Marines can reopen the
roads Marines say that they can resupply
themselves for defensive purposes with
helicopters but all that's very limited
the Marines won't be able to move out
and in force until the road dries out
now whether the North Vietnamese are
going to use this period to continue to
shell the Marines or whether they'll try
something more substantial is of course
something that nobody on this side can
answer but during the monsoons Con Thien
is most isolated air power is most
limited and the Marines will be most
vulnerable the big question really seems
to be whether or not the North
Vietnamese intend to overrun content the
Marines have
triple the number of troops guarding the
outpost and they've moved up more
battalions to be ready to reinforce if
the north vietnamese decided a cat
content they must know it will cost them
between five and ten thousand casualties
they've only decided to do that once
before in 1954 when they felt it would
be the final victory and it was but the
United States could survive the loss of
content get more troop backs and retake
it so it would not seem to be in the
best interest of the North Vietnamese to
attack content in the near future
they'll probably continue to shell it
and the Marines will continue to take it
two years ago when the first of 500,000
Americans began settling into their
enclaves here with the fresh Pentagon
promises of a quick victory the generals
were promoting the new military strategy
of the air mobile offense now in the
light of content the generals are
explaining their successes with the
words mobile defense mobile defense
seems to mean putting 3,000 men on the
ground and allowing them to sit in the
mud and wait for the show with their
name on it the military can no longer
justify this war with a casualty count
it may be that more Marines are dying
along the DMZ than enemy anyway no one
doubts general Geoff's strategy of
sacrificing ten of his own for one
American and few here believe our own
exaggerated guesses at enemy casualties
the Marines have not run any operations
into the DMZ since this summer because
there are not enough regiments to be
sure a victory they stay fairly close to
their bases to within a few hundred
yards for most it begins to sound like a
conventional war with a conventional
front and in a few years the Marines who
have come down off Conn Chen will talk
as proudly as those who came back from
the Chosun reservoir what it all seems
to mean is that American marines have
been committed to protect a key outpost
along a cleared fortified barrier who
was originally conceived in controversy
and at present cannot be constructed
what seems to be overlooked is the
ability of the North Vietnamese to
escalate this war step-by-step with
Washington you begin to suspect that
we've reached the limits of our present
strategy when the generals are talking
openly about an invasion of the north
and the men around content are talking
about the need for tactical nuclear
weapons there seems little doubt that it
is the administration's resolve to stay
at Con Thien the president made that
clear last Friday night in his speech to
the nation when he pointed to the
Marines up at the DMZ as the real
peacekeepers Lyndon Johnson understands
that a defeat or even a withdrawal now a
con TN could be for him a political dn
bein Phu the president's dilemma is how
to persuade the North Vietnamese to quit
up there up to now pure firepower hasn't
done it and it seems unlikely that he
would order American troops into North
Vietnam to do the job Moscow and Peking
would be bound to react sharply to such
an escalation meantime for the Marines
at County and the months ahead look
grimmer than ever the fall monsoon rains
have just begun they will go on till
February hampering American airpower
depriving the men on the ground of at
least some of the air support they
desperately need the artillery duel at
Con Thien will go on and on this battle
is different from any other action in
the war again that there is no left
day-after unchanging day as long as the
north vietnamese can resupply their
troops and guns as long as they can send
down reinforcements there is little the
Marines can do about
Mike Wallace CBS News New York
CBS news film cameraman at Con Thien
Keith K Jerrod P John Smith Carl
Sorensen Kurt Volker PB wad and a CBS
News sound man Pham van wey velu prod
boom fan Chan Penang here on C DV read
Fan Tan gone